so let me know if this has ever happened
to you you get really excited about
starting a new diet you're starting to
feel like crap about yourself and you
think a new diet will solve all your
problems
so you start doing some research online
you read one article about the keto diet
and how it's changing millions of lives
and then you read another article about
how the Paleo diet is the way to go and
then you keep on going down the rabbit
hole and you get into veganism and you
get into the carnivore diet which is
completely a 180 from veganism
something tells me people on the
carnivore diet don't hate vegans but
vegans really hate people on the
carnivore diet but anyways this kind of
situation often happened to me but more
about starting a business back in
university I was pretty stressed about
making my tuition payments and I was
really frustrated with my financial
situation so I would often look online
for best online businesses to start in
2019 and I'd read articles about how
dropshipping will make you millions of
dollars then I would watch another video
talking about how dropshipping is dead
and you missed the boat so you should
start your own digital marketing agency
or something like that the point I'm
trying to make is that we live in the
information age and this is supposed to
mean that we have an abundance of
knowledge and no matter what we want to
do we can learn how to do it we can be
whatever we want to be and we can learn
how to be that thing usually for free
online using the internet well this is
technically true we do have this unique
problem there is so much information out
there so many people telling you what
the right thing to do is that it often
contradicts other people and it all just
becomes a wash we're kind of paralyzed
by the amount of information not really
knowing what path to take being someone
who spends so much time on the Internet
this was especially a problem for me but
luckily I've adopted a mindset that
really helps me cut through the crap and
just get on with my life I'm finding it
it's my preferred philosophy for life in
general and this philosophy or mindset I
call the shoot first mentality rather
than obsessively deliberating over what
path to take just start walking one
making bold uncalculated decisions
firing from the hip is often the
antidote to this endless deliberation if
you make bold courageous decisions
at the drop of a hat and make this your
default mode of solving problems just
trying something noticing it doesn't
work trying again revising having this
action first policy can offer a plethora
of benefits firstly with an action first
mindset you can get better at things
quicker than people who are sitting on
the sidelines reading about it a great
example of this is when I started this
channel I had been really thinking about
the proper way to make a
self-improvement channel and theorizing
about like whether there was a opening
in the market for me or if it was too
saturated or how I could make myself
stand out by the time I made my first
video none of that really mattered
making my first video presented
challenges that I never knew I would
have and I was able to improve upon them
with every single video and I think it's
2 or 3 years later Here I am things are
going very well and I've learned a lot
along the way getting your hands dirty
making mistakes trying new things is by
far the fastest way to learn it's way
faster than reading about it by watching
videos about it actually being in the
act of doing the thing that you want to
do and failing at it will make you get
better faster than anything else the
second benefit of adopting an action
first mindset is that it hardens you or
as David Goggins would say it calluses
your mind and this is all about getting
used to discomfort if you train yourself
to battle past the discomfort of taking
immediate acute action then you're able
to embrace that feeling you're able to
push past the resistance holding you
back from doing what's right rather than
what's comfortable this makes you a very
strong and capable individual in times
of crisis where people are losing their
heads because something really tragic is
happening is something uncomfortable but
necessary needs to be done you'll be the
kind of person who can stand there and
do that type of thing coz you're an
action taker you're not somebody who
worries and stays in their head you look
for the opportunity to take the
necessary action and you execute on it
Ralph Waldo Emerson has this great quote
do the thing and you will have the power
it's hilarious quote because it's so
simple but it's also a very popular
quote be
it's so simply true it's really good at
describing the one-to-one relationship
between action and results nothing else
will move anything other than action
thinking about it
theorizing about it worrying about it
fantasizing about it nothing changes
anything except taking action do the
thing and you'll have the power another
reason why having an action first
mindset is superior to a planning first
mindset is because with an action first
mindset you're gonna get burned but the
lessons you learn by getting burned are
the ones you remember so I have a pretty
funny story about this we're told our
whole life that gossiping is bad don't
talk about other people behind their
backs
you know don't talk basically I was also
told this my whole life the reason why
didn't really register I just knew it
was bad don't do it but fast forward to
when I was about 16 there I was at a
social outing and I started going off
about how stupid some ladies outfit was
that I saw and ice kept on going on
about it just to get attention to myself
I was hoping to get a few laughs
ridiculing this one lady's outfit that
we could all relate to and after going
on about it for like 130 whole seconds I
realized that no one's really laughing
at all in fact they look pretty
uncomfortable and that was because sure
enough that lady's daughter was one of
the girls I was talking to it was the
one of the most devastating moments of
my life my heart completely sank I
turned into a shell of a human being
definitely top three most embarrassing
moments of my life and I can guarantee
you I never made that mistake again but
do I regret it I don't because I was
firing from the hip I got burned and I'm
a better person because of it before my
last thought just a quick word from
today's video sponsor audible so the
audio book I'm currently listening to is
can't hurt me by David Goggins and I'm
pretty late to the party with David
Goggins I actually just discovered him
but I'm blown away by the amount of
action this guy takes this guy is
absolutely crazy the amount of stuff
he's accomplished I don't want to spoil
it there's actually a really good reason
to get the audible version specifically
because David Goggins interjects with
his own wisdom and off-the-cuff thoughts
after the narrator reads the chapter
it's actually like a really cool almost
pod
see type of feel would highly recommend
it audible has the largest library of
audiobooks on the entire Internet with
an audible subscription you can download
one book of your choice absolutely free
every single month along with two
audible originals
since audible is offering better ideas
viewers a 30-day free trial that means
you can listen to can't hurt me by David
Goggins right now absolutely free so to
sign up for your free trial click the
link in the description or go to
audible.com slash better ideas or text
better ideas to 500 500 the nice thing
about audible is that if you don't like
your audiobook you can easily exchange
it for something else
and if at any time you cancel your
subscription you still keep your entire
library of audiobooks so once again to
sign up for your free 30 day trial
either click the link in the description
go to audible.com slash for better ideas
or text better ideas to 500 500
ok guys I'll leave you with this there's
a lot of people who fit into this
category somebody who chronically thinks
of business ideas you have a million
dollar business idea every second week
you're always thinking of new things
that could blossom into your financial
freedom and say you do this say you're
thinking of business ideas for five
years and you still haven't started a
business within those five years you've
probably thought of several
multi-million dollar business ideas you
probably have but nothing came of it
because you never learned how to develop
a business action taking wasn't your
first instinct theorizing and planning
and fantasizing was the kinds of people
who develop multi-million dollar
businesses don't have any more special
thoughts than you do they just have
special application they've been digging
in the trenches trying and failing
learning how to start a business
juggling the logistics of running one
successfully failing a few more times
and eventually stumbling into improving
their strategies and getting to the
point where they're comfortable managing
a business and when they think of their
million-dollar idea they know how to
apply it they just go and do it but if
you never learned to take action your
ideas will always be just that ideas if
you like this video make sure to hit
like because when you hit the like
button the Algar
them does fancy things and it shoves
this video in front of other people's
faces and my bald head
arrives in people's home pages and
they're like who's this guy but that's
how my channel gets discovered and I
really would appreciate it if you hit
that like button so I can help more
people out and if you're lurking here
and this is like the millionth time
you've seen my face and you still
haven't hit subscribe not only should
you hit subscribe but you should hit the
Bell icon so you can join our
ever-growing notification squad
I call it a notification squad but it's
kind of cringy you get notifications
when I post a video and the benefit to
that is when you post a comment when
you're early
I can heart or respond to the comments
and as the channel grows it's harder to
have individual conversations with every
one of my audience members so there's
your chance to do it become a part of
the notification conglomerate but other
than that yeah that's all for today
thank you for watching and we'll catch
you in the next video
[Music]
you